Hey guys, I’m Abbey Sharp and welcome to
Abbey’s Kitchen.
In today’s edition of What I Eat in a Day
Youtuber reviews, I will be taking a look
at Stephanie Joshi from the YouTube channel
Nutty Foodie Fitness.
Stephanie is a model and fitness enthusiast
and is known for her WIEIAD videos and eating
challenges.
Some examples of the food challenge videos
on her channel include the ever so popular
“10,000 calorie challenge”, “only eating
sweet food for 24 hours”, “eating peanut
butter for 24 hours” “eating nothing but
pizza for a day” … You get the gist.
This also sounds eerily similar to our friend
Livia Adams from Always Hungry, but I am hoping
we get a different narrative
from Stephanie.
So, let’s meet Stephanie and take a look
at her first meals of
the day.
Like the vast majority of us, Stephanie is
currently in self isolation and let’s just
say, the struggle is real.
I can totally relate to the stress of not
finding the usual essential food items at
the store now a days.
I would say that its more than a disappointment
when your go-to staples aren’t available,
for me, its actually stressful, especially
because I know I cant just pick it up somewhere
else so easily.
Also, you guys need to know that I washed
my hair for you all today and Im now doing
that legit just once a week because I only
see you guys once a week ha.
So yah, my hair, nails and skin better look
amazing after this is all done.
let’s take a look at what she has for breakfast
on day one.
What a gorgeous oatmeal bowl and I love the
apple pie flavour.
I am a big fan of oats in the morning because
they are rich in carbs and fiber to help keep
you satiated.
The specific fibre in oats beta glucan has
also been shown to help lower cholesterol
which is probably not an issue for stephanie,
but is a really huge selling point for a lot
of other adults.
One thing we need to be mindful of is balancing
it out with a source of protein, especially
at breakfast.
That would usually come from the milk that’s
added to the oats, but since Stephanie is
using a milk alternative like oat milk, the
protein content is kind of lacking here.
So even though we have a good amount of carbs
from the oats, apple, and granola, and also
some healthy fats from the chia seed, I would
love to see a little extra protein from nut
butter, protein powder, Greek yogurt, or a
little more chia or hemp on top, or an egg
or two on
the side.
Okay so here we are seeing Stephanie eating
a substantially larger breakfast than she
did on day 1.
She mentions having already eaten oats for
breakfast (4:44), then has a bite of her friend’s
leftover scrambled eggs, two pieces of toast
with smoked salmon, egg, and avocado, and
two pancakes.
It’s a lot of food, but I mean, we can all
relate to the hotel brunch effect I will call
it.
It’s actually quite normal to eat more than
you may normally while travelling, partially
because you may be walking more, have more
food options available to you, or you’re
just influenced by the eating patterns of
others around you.
Having said that, it still does feel like
a lot of food at once in comparison to her
day 1 breakfast.
Now we are still learning about Stephanie,
so I don’t know if she just has a normal
hearty appetite, or if this is like a cheat
day / eating challenge situation.
A lot of people who are stuck in diet culture,
find that having a big “cheat meal like
breakfast” can kinda set them up for a binge
the rest of the day.
It’s kinda like the “oh I just blew my
diet, might as well continue down this course
for the rest of the day and then tighten the
reigns tomorrow.”
So I’m interested to see how the rest of
that day unfolds.
But first, breakfast 3.
Okay so this oatmeal breakfast looks great
and is my favourite of the three– we’ve
got healthy carbs from the oats and banana,
protein from the salted caramel protein powder
and some peanut butter for healthy fats.
So this would be a more balanced option than
her day 1 oatmeal bowl, but just as delicious.
She also added in some toffee flavoured drops,which
have no calories, sugar or fat.
Theyre basically just a sweetener made with
sucralose which is like Splenda along with
some natural flavours and caramel colour syrup.
So that’s a fine add in if you want to cut
back on sugar.
but if you haven’t watched my video on artificial
sweeteners, check it out right here.
Let’s see whats next.
Okay so we clearly have a peanut butter lover
on our hands here which makes sense in the
context of her moniker.
So after her oatmeal breakfast, Stephanie
is having a little apple with 20 spoonfuls
of peanut butter as a mid-morning snack.
Now, I love the combination of apples and
nut butter because we have fibre, protein
and healthy fat, but the ratio of apple to
nut butter is a little off.
Nut butter is really energy dense so it’s
very easy to eat a large amount of calories
in a small package, which is amazing for those
trying to gain weight or bulk up.
And as Stephanie sort of mentions later on
in her videos, she does refer to going to
the gym to “make gains”, so this may be
the case for her.
But for most people, 1 or 2 tablespoons would
be sufficient for a balanced snack and 20
tablespoons might look a bit like a binge.
Again, im still getting to know her style
so obviously I’m not making any assumptions.
She does however mention that she has 4 different
jars of peanut butter beside her bed, which
may be triggering for some people.
I always recommend keeping food in the kitchen
or pantry, and actually putting your food
in a bowl or plate to eat out of, rather than
mindlessly snacking out of a jar or big bag.
If you’re still hungry after you finish
the food in your bowl, by all means, go get
more, but but eating food in a more purposeful
way just helps you get more in tune with your
hunger and fullness cues as you move through
your intuitive eating journey.
Lets
take a look at lunch.
So Stephanie mentions a few supplements she
has, not sure if shes necessarily taking them
or just that shes promoting them as an affiliate,
but a few things to note on this.
One, a reminder to influencers to disclose
your partnerships at the top of the video,
I think ive said enough about that.
And two, let’s talk about hair strengthening
supplements.
Now I have NO clue whats in this particular
gummy because she doesn’t say, but speaking
from a nutrition perspective – there are
several vitamins and minerals that certainly
play a role in hair growth and strengthening
including Vitamin A, B Vitamins, Vitamin C,
Vitamin D, Vitamin D, Iron, Zinc, and Protein.
However, its important to note that these
natural supplements are not well regulated
meaning that many of them are not approved
by the FDA.
So theres no real research to prove whether
or not certain supplements, like a hair supplement,
even work, and the claims a lot of these companies
make are off base.
So I’m not suggesting that they don’t
work, they might help, but having a balanced
healthy diet and good hair genes – which
she clearly does - is also key.
Okay so before her breakfast, she did a little
mini workout in her kitchen doing some push
ups, and then shortly after we’re seeing
a classic English Breakfast with bacon, eggs,
garlic mushrooms, tomatoes, noodles, a bagel
and baked beans.
I didn’t know the brits had noodles for
breakfast- but my british fans, is that common?
I want to know!
Anyway, lots going on here.
We got protein from the baked beans, bacon,
and eggs; some veggie action with the tomato
and mushroom; carbs from the bagel and noodles.
She is also not afraid to add fat to her meal
as she coated the frying pan with butter,
which is refreshing to see, given the “no
oil trend” is so rampant in the wellness
community.
But if she wanted to balance out the higher
amounts of saturated fat from the bacon, eggs
and butter, she could have opted for an unsaturated
fat like olive oil for cooking in.
It’s a hearty meal and definitely one that
is higher in animal fat and more refined carbs
than I would want to recommend regularly,
but we are living in unusual times right now,
so its normal for your eating patterns to
be unusual.
A lot of us are turning to more comfort foods
while in isolation and that is totally normal
– ive talked about that extensively here.
So I’m totally okay with these kinds of
meals in moderation, especially in the context
of stephanie’s day because she had a low
fat, low protein breakfast with the oats.
Let’s take a look at day 2.
Haha okay that guy knows where its at – chocolate
orange combo is the WORST.
Like this video if you agree haha just kidding.
Okay so after their epic hotel brunch, she’s
doing a tour of a protein powder factory,
the one that I guess shes an affiliate for
(but doesn’t really properly disclose).
So it makes sense now that she wanted to have
a larger meal because she was going to be
out and about before she could eat again.
I mean, this is super typical for travel days
so I’m glad she was able to anticipate her
day and plan her eating accordingly – though
it does look like she was at least able to
sample some of the protein drinks as
a little snack.
Now stephanie is on the way to the gym with
her friends and we see that she has a BCAA
beverage and some truffle chocolates, which
were later followed up with a fruit smoothie.
This actually looks like a pretty good pre-workout
snack.
We are getting some fast digesting carbs from
the fruit smoothie which you want to have
prior to a workout to give you energy, and
also a BCAA beverage.
BCAA’s stand for Branched Chain Amino Acids
and they are commonly taken as a supplement
containing 3 essential amino acids leucine,
isoleucine and valine.
While there is some research that BCAAs may
aid in muscle soreness and fatigue and muscle
mass, most research does not suggest this
is superior to getting a complete source of
protein with all 9 essential amino acids from
more cost effective food or a supplement like
whey protein.
So by all means, take BCAAs to support your
workout if you find they work for you, but
you can also get adequte amounts in your diet
from foods like tofu, beans, meat, poultry,
fish, eggs, pumpkin seeds, and quinoa.
Okay so not surprisingly given Stephanies
larger than normal breakfast, she doesn’t
have a full lunch this day, just the supplements
and smoothie which is probably because she’s
not that full.
I’m glad she got a little fuel in the tank
pre-workout and that she was just listening
to her body’s needs rather than pulling
a typical cheat day stunt where she started
the day off with a larger than normal meal,
and then said oh screw it, I guess I will
just eat everything I can.
Lets take a look at day 3.
Oh my god, where is this restaurant?
The food looks amazing and almost too pretty
to eat.
But also I think this girl legit ordered everything
in the menu, and it looks like she does a
pretty good job of polishing it off- down
to the balsamic glaze on her plate.
We got the layered smoothie, pancakes, avocado
toast on a waffle, a chicken sandwich with
salad, cheese tortellini, AND a pistachio
donut.
That is a total of 5 full lunch entrees AND
a dessert.
It’s hard to know if she’s shared everything
or not, but regardless, it’s a large amount
of food, so I am a bit concerned this is teetering
in eating challenge/ cheat day territory.
Lets check out her snacks.
So after a carb heavy breakfast, a fat and
protein heavy lunch, we’re back for a sweet
treat here for afternoon tea.
Wow.
Okay so this matcha chia pudding-like concoction
that Stephanie made for her snack is pretty
genius, I have to say.
Though it does have a dessert-like feel with
the matcha kit kat, its still pretty nutrient
dense.
We have some protein from the protein powder
and yogurt, healthy fats from the chia seed
and peanut butter, and carbs from the banana
and granola.
I will say in combination with the two cake
slices she just had, we are definitely racking
up the added sugar.
So far we’re at roughly 150 g of sugar this
day, and we still have meals to come.
Now day 2, which was her restaurant travel
day, she doesn’t have another snack, so
let’s move along to
day 3.
So, based on this short little clip it appears
that Stephanie eats spoonful’s of peanut
butter as her pre-workout snack.
Though we don’t see how many she has exactly,
she is also coming off the heels of her massive
brunch meal so I imagine she must still be
feeling pretty full from that.
But also, this is also the same day that she
had 20 spoonful’s of peanut butter, so I
really can’t be sure where her relationship
with food and her appetite is that day.
From a more practical nutrition science stand
point, straight up peanut butter is not the
best preworkout snack.
The fat slows down the rate of digestion,
and it doesn’t deliver the fast acting carbs
that we need to perform.
Ideally we want to have the majority of the
fat in our day spaced out away from our workouts,
so maybe if she was hungry before she trained,
a combination of carbs and protein would have
been a better choice.
Exact amounts would depend on the length of
time between when she ate and when she hit
the gym.
But if lets say Stephanie ate 30 minutes before
her workout, she would want to aim for about
10-20 grams of carbs, which might look like
one banana or one fruit, either on their own
or with some Greek yogurt for protein to boost
the satiety factor.
Lets see what dinner has in store.
Yes, I LOVE this.
I love slow cooker meals like this, and this
looks perfectly balanced.
We got some protein from the chicken, carbs
from the potato, and of course a ton of bright
and colourful veggies.
I’m happy to see that after a sugar heavy
snack on this day, we’ve got a really nutrient
dense meal to end the day.
Okay so
for most people who have had a hearty brunch
with lots of carbs and fat, I would say yah,
this dinner totally makes sense.
We have satiating protein and fat from the
steak and edamame, and lots of veg with the
rapini.
But considering she just completed a pretty
heavy duty workout, I would have liked to
see some carbs to replenish glycogen stores.
Lets take a look at day 3.. this one meal
might tell us
a lot.
Hm ... yah, this is kinda what I was afraid
of with stephanie’s day 3.
So we have chicken wings, chicken strips,
coleslaw, coke, ice cream, cookies, and a
few different pizzas.
This scene is playing out exactly like any
mukbang or cheat day challenge, and in the
context of her day with a big oatmeal breakfast,
peanut butter, huge brunch, more peanut butter,
and now, all of this – it is definitely
feeling potentially problematic.
At one point even her friend comments on how
much she’s eaten.
I get that she’s trying to make “gains”
but there are definitely more nourishing ways
to go about that that will satisfy her nutritional
needs without an excessive amount of saturated
fat, salt and sugar.
Now I am all for ordering in occasionally,
and pizza night is a Friday night tradition
in my house, but shes just consumed 90 grams
of saturated fat and 15,800 mg of sodium in
this one meal alone.
That is 10 times more than the recommended
amount of sodium and 7 times the amount of
saturated fat for the day.
Consuming that much sodium in one sitting
has the potential to not only cause bloating,
and over time, significantly increase blood
pressure.
Basically, a diet that is consistently high
in sodium can injure blood vessel walls, contributing
to plaque build up.
This blocks blood flow which makes the heart
work harder to pump blood throughout the body,
increasing the risk of heart attack, stroke,
and heart failure.
When it comes to saturated fat and heart health,
the research is mixed as this is a bit of
a controversial topic.
The relationship between saturated fat and
heart disease is not 100% clear.
BUT, dietary guidelines do continue to suggest
limiting saturated fat in the diet because
it MAY have negative implications for heart
health.
But regardless, I cannot speak for Stephanie,
but consuming 7 times the amount of saturated
fat in one sitting cant possibly feel good
for most people.
Okay so let’s finish things off with dessert.
So clearly stephanie is a matcha fan, and
those look like cute little treats.
Now while matcha may help have some brain
and heart health benefits, one thing to keep
in mind is it has greater amount of caffeine
than green tea, so it might not be great idea
to have them before bed.
I also feel like shes had a sugar heavy day
this day as is, so if she were hungry before
bed, maybe something like cottage cheese or
yogurt with some fresh fruit would have been
a more balanced choice.
Okay so now I know that If we are to ever
go out to eat with Stephanie that we cannot
leave our food unattended ha, but okay so
that looks delish.
I guess it’s a good thing we’re getting
some carbs with that dinner after the workout,
but would have been ideal to get more complex
carbs so that she doesn’t get a sugar crash
in the night.
While you may feel sleepy after a carb heavy
meal aka a carb coma, research suggests that
sugar can interfere with deep sleep, which
will leave you feeling less rested the next
day.
Lets see day 3.
Okay, so its very clear to
me here that we have a lot more going on that
maybe we don’t see on stephanie’s channel.
It’s possible we’re dealing with the “extreme
hunger” weve heard other influencers talk
about like stephanie buttermore or always
hungry, as these meals and days look very
much the same.
Okay so let me give you my overall thoughts
on this series of what I eat in a day.
in general, is this way of eating balanced?
I am having a lot of mixed feelings watching
a lot of Stephanie’s videos and having a
hard time reading them.
On the one hand, I love her enthusiasm for
food.
I also just love watching her because I think
shes got a real vibrant energy and is super
cute and sweet.
She also made a specific disclaimer in her
day 3 video about it not being a cheat day,
take a look.
So I love this philosophy and share it wholeheartedly.
So I think it’s great that this day
of
eating isn’t a special day, and that she
isn’t going to then restrict heavily the
next day.
She also addresses peoples assumptions
that she’s bulimic.
Okay so here we see Stephanie talk about how
her appetite has always been larger than average,and
that no two people’s nutritional needs are
the same so not to compare.
That’s true and that’s a really important
message to share.
None of this means stephanie has an eating
disorder, or that she is necessarily restricting,
or that she is throwing up her food.
None of that is the necessary truth.
We don’t know that, I don’t know that.
I am admittedly just a bit troubled by what
to say here because the reality is, I don’t
know everything about stephanie.
All I see are the videos she posts but from
what I do see, I do have some concerns., Her
experience does remind me of stephanie buttermore’s
“extreme hunger” as she went through her
All In Journey.
But what we saw with Stephanie Buttermore’s
experience, was extreme hunger as a result
of extreme calorie restriction which totally
altered her hunger and satiety hormones and
actually damaged a number of biological functions.
It’s actually true that in these circumstances
– that is, when you have a history of restriction
and associated low body fat, the body may
actually need a drastic amount of calories
to provide basic nutrition for basic daily
needs PLUS extra to repair the damage.
What can happen is that your enteric nervous
system (that is the reflex circuits in your
gut) is receiving information that you’re
physically full, yet the central nervous system
(aka your brain) is receiving information
that more energy is required to return to
a balanced state.
The drive to eat a lot of calories- even 10,000
calories, is very normal in this circumstance,
and should be honoured as its all about energy
restoration or building back what is maybe
not working optimally.
There is good evidence to support this process,
as crazy as it may sound, so I’ll link to
some really good resources below.
Now I want to reiterate that I do not know
if this stephanie is restricting on the days
she isn’t showing on her channel like buttermore
did, but I just wanted to share that information
on what we know about extreme hunger in general.
What I can say is that between these three
what I eat in a day videos, nevermind the
official eating challenges she puts up, there
is a huge range in caloric consumption.
According to our calculations, Stephanie consumed
3000 calories on day 1, 1750 calories on day
2, and a total of 11, 430 calories on day
3.
That’s quite the range, my friends.
And after taking a look at her macros, her
fat intake is either on the higher end of
the 20-35% total calorie recommendation or
totally surpasses it.
Now it’s normal- very very normal- for us
not to eat the same amount of calories each
day.
But these discrepancies are pretty extreme.
One study suggested that that average daily
caloric variability for women would be + or
- 25% of their total energy needs.. which
would mean that Stephanie caloric intake would
ideally sit within a 1650 – 2750 caloric
range.
but from these three videos, only one of Stephanies
WIEIAD’s is within this range and I assume
if we were to also factor in a lot of her
other eating challenge videos, we would see
even greater discrepancy.
Also, even if Stephanie is in a bulk phase,
which I’m just speculating by her use of
hashtags like #gains on her instagram, her
day 3 contains substantially more food than
what we would typically see in even a man’s
bulk phase.
Again, everyone’s normal needs are super
unique, but I’m just speaking to patterns
and averages I see.
I would also say that even if this variability
is normal for her, and is not the result of
“extreme hunger” or previous restriction,
which they very well may be, again, I cant
deny her that legitimate possibility, I would
have liked to see her meet those needs in
a more balanced way.
Sugar, salt and saturated fat are all fine
in moderation, but there are days she’s
getting 10x the amount of sodium, 16 x the
amount of saturated fat, and 6 x the amount
of sugar to meet her needs.
Like we mentioned, excessive intake of sodium
is linked to bloating, and high blood pressure
which can put one at risk for heart disease.
Too much sugar can likewise increase the risk
of heart disease and can also lead to increased
risk of developing type 2 diabetes, weight
gain, acne, and cancer..…..
Especially if shes going to continue with
these eating challenges which are even more
extreme, I would just want to be mindful of
her usual diet.
Now, are there any problematic claims or assumptions
made by this channel?
So I actually really like stephanie’s attitude
towards food.
We do not see Stephanie using any diet-y language
whatsoever.
She also does not seem to be overly preoccupied
with her weight, or what she eats, or how
much, which I like.
I would just flag that again, some of her
content may be triggering for a lot of people
who struggle in their relationship with food
because her behaviours can read as problematic,
even if they aren’t actually for her, if
that makes sense.
Finally, what can we take away from Stephanie’s
channel?
I would say the biggest take away for me is
stephanies glowing and fun personality.
I love that she loves food, and for me, she
herself is really a pleasure to watch, even
if I sometime find her meal schemes hard to
enjoy.
Bottom Line
Though I do appreciate Stephanie’s enthusiasm
and openness with food, I do worry about how
this may be interpreted by her viewers who
may have struggled or are currently struggling
with disordered eating or an eating disorder.
It is totally healthy and balanced to enjoy
pizza or a matcha flavoured donut from time
to time.
It’s also okay to occasionally eat a lof
ot peanut butter off the spoon.
But taken together with the plethora of extreme
eating challenges, insatiable hunger, and
strange nut butter rituals, I just worry about
how it will all be interpreted by vulnerable
viewers.
I also think there are definitely much more
balanced ways to get your calories in – even
if they are extreme- that don’t look like
multiple pizzas, ice cream, and wings in one
sitting.
While I do think Stephanie is trying to set
a good example for her followers by demonstrating
that you don’t need to be afraid of food,
and you can enjoy food without being overly
preoccupied with weight or wrapped up in diet
culture, I would have liked to see her communicate
this message physically in a more balanced
and consistent way.
I want to conclude by reminding you all to
be kind in the comments, both to me and to
Stephanie if you do choose to reach out.
We need to work to support people through
their eating journeys, not to tear them down
and criticize them for being “wrong”.
There is no right or wrong in this situation,
we’re all just using our own unique set
of coping strategies to get by.
and on that note, that all for this today’s
video.
If you liked this video, please be sure to
give it a big thumbs up.
Leave me a comment below with who you would
like to see me review next.
Until then, subscribe to the channel, like
this video, and i’ll see you next time on
Abbey’s Kitchen.
Bye!